hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on done appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become hi guys welcome back to
another workout today's workout will be
targeting your back fat and also that a
bra pouch area that area just under your
armpit so the exercises will be focusing
on your upper back as well as the back
part of your shoulders what you'll need
is a pair of lightweight dumbbells and
also another pair of medium weight
dumbbells so let's get started for the
first workout what we'll be doing is a
dumbbell high row so instead of your
usual dumbbell row stand shoulder width
apart with your toes pointed forward
instead of pulling both dumbbells
towards your waist what I'm going to do
is pull it just under your chest okay so
high up spread your wings and just
directly under your chest
so for each workout we wanted to work on
45 seconds with 15 seconds rest in
between okay get ready
it's that sugar with a pot lower down
your body and remember pulling the
dumbbell just directly under your chest
there you go spread your elbows to the
sides good so it's a white row squeezing
your back again let's go spread and just
you should feel the mid part of your
back as well as your aqua back squeeze
hope for two counts release pull it
squeeze release up and down good so for
this workout you want to go for medium
weight I would say between five to seven
kilos each keep going remember chest up
and keep your back flat squeeze last few
more squeeze last one more squeeze and
good drop it down now let's go for a
pair of lighter weights okay the second
workout is going to be a reverse fly
with rotation so again with back workout
Oeste
should with a pad been from your waist
reverse fly spread your wings and rotate
your shoulders
I mean rotate your arms good you should
feel the work on your shoulders as well
good bring it together spread your wings
rotate and bring it back so it's just a
slight rotation on your forearm control
it hover it and rotate it good nice and
controlled bring you back down spread it
back down good open up squeeze your mid
your upper back the back part of your
shoulders that's where we want to be
targeting few more last one more squeeze
and back it down alright third exercise
around the world okay so what I want you
to do is bring both dumbbells right in
front of you with the pumps facing
forward what I want to do is lift both
dumbbells up straight up over your head
bring it back down okay and not back up
again and I want to bring the dumbbells
back and squeeze your back muscles bring
it up over control back and squeeze your
back muscles good so over and back and
squeeze your back good over and again
back very nice let's go straight arms
for all these exercises you don't have
to lift heavy okay if you don't have a
pair of dumbbells use a couple of water
bottles back down nice and control whew
your shoulders back bring it back to
squeeze on your back good and now let's
get down onto the floor okay this is
going to be a plank with lateral arm
rest so if you find this challenging in
the wrist what you can do is place one
pump on the floor and all I want to do
is bring the dumbbell to the side drop
it down and alternate spread it out to
the side type in your core brace your
core
and work on your shoulders as well as
your upper back so bring it squeeze and
back down and alternate if you want to
you can place both hands on the dumbbell
squeeze back down squeeze and bring it
back down okay
strengthening your wrist at the same
time nice keep going
nice and controlled do not swing your
hips good keep your hips in line very
nice find a workout okay it's going to
be Superman squeeze okay this workout is
more challenging so what I want to do is
lie down you can choose to do it without
any weights on lift a really light pair
of down those start in a Superman
position lift it up bring it back
squeeze it bring it straight hover
squeeze do not drop it straight squeeze
your back straight ahead
whoa I can feel the burn on my shoulders
straight squeeze and keep going straight
ahead squeeze slowly for one count
squeeze brace your core squeeze it this
if this is too much drop the weights do
it without any weights squeeze stretch
forward squeeze for two counts and keep
going breathe in and out ahhh
one more and good now rest it out okay
take a one-minute break and we want to
repeat all the exercises for another two
more rounds so the first workout will be
dumbbell high row lift slightly heavier
if you want to drop grab some water or
wipe your sweat okay
so again remember with all the back
exercises don't rush the workout okay
remember to squeeze for at least two
counts release and then pull squeeze for
two counts and then release
don't rush the work out what is most
important is that you feel the
engagement on your upper back this part
your mid-back as well as your wings this
is where we want to be toning up on this
area right here okay right so let's get
ready dumbbell high rope grab the
dumbbells Stan sugar with a pot okay
fifteen more seconds breathe in roll
your shoulders relax it and let's go
down and remember squeezing up just
directly under your chest back down and
up spread your elbows squeeze good open
up your elbows to the sides
squeeze it pull and squeeze nice
remember gaze at the floor keeping your
neck neutral pull and squeeze without
and breathe in keep going cool it
squeeze nice
if this is too heavy again start with a
lighter pair of dumbbells squeeze last
few more last one more and now drop it
let's go for light weight all right
reverse fly with rotation okay let's go
back down stand sugar with a pot spread
your wings with a rotation on your
forearm spread rotate nice and control
and back down remember to keep your
elbows slightly bent okay do not lock
them keep them slightly bent and rotate
good view the work on your shoulders as
you rotate your wrists rotate nice and
controlled up twist and back it down
whoa nice work this workout
it's about isolating your back muscles
okay we're just working on the back part
and if you can do this workout at least
two to three times weekly alright around
the world already not an easy workout
but a really effective workout ok so
start with the palms facing forward okay
and bring the dumbbells together let's
go bring it up over in front of your
face and bring it back down control and
up it's when you control the dumbbells
that's when you will be working on your
muscles don't just let it drop up
control squeeze your shoulders back down
and now let's go towards the back part
front and back okay squeeze your back
nice and controlled front and squeeze
bring your shoulder blades together back
down squeeze nice few more squeeze it
remember brace your core keep your body
straight
and now let's get down onto the floor
okay it's going to be a plank with
lateral grace alright get up into a high
plank choose your option place one pump
on the floor if you want to and raise it
up to the side squeeze two counts one
two back down
hold it up one two down and up I can see
my sweat dripping down okay up keeping a
heart rate up as well to constantly burn
calories down release up squeeze it down
squeeze good keep alternating raise your
core you're also working when you call
muscles last few more one more and good
now one of the most challenging workout
look at me
absolutely Ceti right let's get down
onto the floor okay if you want just
lift one kilo that is enough
okay so let's go Superman up squeeze
pull squeeze forward squeeze and squeeze
if you want to drop for a while
lift it up squeeze bring it back down
drop it up again squeeze back down and
drop whoa oh my gosh I'm absolutely
burning squeeze and back it down last
few more three more one back down let's
go to one more three and back
all right good job now take another
minute break okay wipe your sweat and
you have one final set breathe in
breathe out and have you want to get
into a child's pose and just take this
time to bring your heart rate down a
little bit stretch your back getting
ready for the final set breathe in and
out
stretch your back very good okay all
right whoa
absolutely sweaty hey it's Monday
morning
we're supposed to be sweaty we're
supposed to be feeling good okay
remember every morning a shot workout is
better than the workout even if you can
only fit in 10 to 15 minutes get your
workout done this workout is under 20
minutes let's go lift the dumbbells step
forward okay
Hiero squeezing your mid-back and your
upper back down and up
spread your elbows squeeze good spread
it and down whoo remember bringing the
dumbbells straight down okay
it's not about bringing the dumbbells
forward this is your own straight down
squeeze and straight down nice breathe
in breathe out every time you squeeze
that's when you breathe out in and out
good job guys keep going if you do this
work I consistently trust me you will
see results and you will not have has
that annoying Bravo CH you will be able
to fit better in your clothes ready for
summer good now drop the weights let's
go for a lighter pair reverse fly with
rotation okay right let's go down and up
up
and rotate back down up and rotate good
keep going up rotate nice come on let's
keep working your muscles and your heart
let's keep them pumping let's continue
to burn calories up and rotate good job
spread it rotate point your elbows back
keep them bent and rotate few more let's
work on five more okay this is your
final set
keep going to count with me
last three three don't rush it last four
give me one more okay one more five and
good all right round the world one of my
favourite shoulder and upper back
workout okay
both pumps forward both dumbbells
together and let's bring them up using
the strength from your arm over and
bring it back squeeze your back bring it
over and again white imagine you're
drawing a big circle around the world
okay back squeeze and bring it forward
and up nice keep going forward up let's
go good suck your belly in tighten your
core do not use the momentum from your
body rely on your upper body to lift the
weights one more all the way up over and
down good plank with lateral raise okay
let's get down onto the floor choose
your option if this is still too
difficult you can always start on your
knees place one palm on the floor start
on your knees and lift it up squeeze it
bring it back down and then alternate
lift it up squeeze back down
and alternate okay eventually what I
want to do is progress and get into a
high plank position
up squeeze engage in your core suck the
belly in up and squeeze
good squeeze it nice Oh
my goal is to see my met soaked in sweat
let's keep going up squeeze back down up
squeeze and back down all right who's
ready for the final workout Superman
squeeze let me know in the comments
below if you're struggling with this
workout because trust me I know your
pain I feel the burn
all right let's go straight arms down up
squeeze squeeze okay
engage your core control the dumbbells
forward squeeze and squeeze
oh this is not easy top it down if you
need to release the weight up do it
without any weights squeeze lift your
back up squeeze forward squeeze and now
let's go okay give me three more up
squeeze forward squeeze one more squeeze
and drop it down
boom very very well done alright what
I'm going to do is just get into a
child's pose and just stretch your back
out release the muscle tension on your
back relax and just lengthen your spine
okay if you want to you can inch your
fingers forward and just drop your butt
close to your heels and stretch it out
you should feel the stretch on your lats
your wings basically take a deep breath
in this out relax slow your heart rate
down and now just bring one arm across
stretch it you should feel a deeper
stretch on your right leg
stretch it out and now change
and now so you bring yourself up okay
well done guys
so that was your workout to bring back
fat as well as drab watch okay this
stubborn area which most of us tend to
be really self-conscious about when we
wear you know tight tank tops or tight
bra that that's always with this
annoying Bravo so do this workout at
least two to three times weekly keep it
consistent if you feel that you can
challenge yourself and lift heavier then
by all means lift the weight heavier
okay if you want to challenge yourself
go for higher reps more reps shorter
rest time I love these exercises I do
them on a regular basis if you love this
workout be sure to share it with your
other girlfriends and check out my other
workout challenges recipes and also
fitness tips on my youtube channel and
I'll see you next week
all the best